let me ask you back to the question of
God and a big ridiculous question who's
God
who is God so I'm going to
um
I'm going to use sort of the Aquinas
formulation of of what God is right that
that if you
if there is a cause of all things not
physical things if there is a cause
underlying the reason of the universe
then that is the thing we call God
so not a big guy in this guy with a
beard you know like he he is the the
force underlying the logic of the
universe if there is a logic to the
universe uh and he is the Creator in the
genetic view of that universe
and he uh and he does have an interest
in us living in accordance with the laws
of the universe that if you're a
religious Jew are encoded in the in the
Torah but if you're not a religious Jew
would be included in the National and
the natural law by sort of Catholic
theology why do you think God created
the universe or as as popularly asked
what do you think is the meaning
behind it what's the meaning of life
what's the meaning of life so I think
that the meaning of life is to fulfill
what God made you to do and that is a
series of roles
I think that human beings and here you
have to look to sort of human nature
rather than looking kind of to Big
questions
I've evolved something that I've really
been working on you know I'm writing a
book about this actually uh that that I
call colloquially role Theory and
basically the idea is that the way that
we interact with the world is through a
series of roles and those are also the
things we find most
important and most implementable and
they they're sort of virtue ethics right
which which suggests that if we act in
accordance with virtue like Aristotle
then we will be living the most
fulfilled and meaningful life and then
you have sort of deontological effects
like content effects that it's a
rule-based ethic
he filed the rules then you'll then
you'll find the meaning of life and then
what I'm proposing is that there's
something that I would call role ethics
which is there are a series of roles
that we play across our lives which are
also the things that we tend to put on
our tombstones and find the most
meaningful so what when you go to a
cemetery you can see what people found
the most meaningful because it's the
stuff they put on the stone that has
like four words on it right like beloved
father beloved mother sister brother
and you might have a job once in a while
a Creator you know a religious person
right these are all roles that have
existed across societies and across
humanity and those are the things where
we actually find meaning and the way
that we navigate those roles brings us
meaning and I think that God created us
in order to fulfill those roles for
purposes that I can't begin to
understand because I am him and the more
we the more we recognize those roles and
the more we we live those roles and then
we can express Freedom within those
roles I think that the Liberty exists
inside each of those roles and that's
what makes all of our Lives different
and fun we all parents in different ways
but being a parent is a meaningful role
we all have spouses
um but you know how you interact that
relationship is what makes your life
meaningful and interesting that that is
that is what we were put on Earth to do
and if we perform those roles properly
and those roles do include things like
being a Creator like we have a creative
Instinct as human beings being a Creator
or being an innovator being uh being a
defender of your family you know being
somebody who builds up being a social
member of your community which is
something that we're built to do if we
fulfill those roles properly then we
will have made the world a better place
than we than we inherited it and we'll
also have have
had the joy of experiencing the the sort
of flow they talk about in in Psychology
where when you engage in these roles you
actually do feel a flow so these roles
are a fundamental part of the human
condition yes so you're the the book
you're working on is is constructing uh
a system to help us understand
it's it's looking at let's assume that
all that's true the real question in the
book is how do you construct a
flourishing and useful
society and politics uh so a society
level if this is our understanding of a
human being how do we construct a good
Society right exactly because I I think
that a lot of political theory is right
now based in either
JS Mill kind of thought which is all
that a good politics does allows you
wave your hand around until you hit
somebody in the face or a rosian thought
which is what if we constructed Society
in order to achieve the most for the
least essentially you know what if we
constructed society around what actually
makes humans the most fulfilled and that
is the the
fulfillment of these particular roles
and where does Liberty come into that
right how do you avoid the idea of a
tyranny in that right how do you you
have to be a mother you must be a father
you must be where does where does
freedom come into that can you reject
those roles totally as a society and be
okay the answer probably is not so you
need a society that actually
promotes and and protects those roles
but also protects the freedom inside
those roles and that raises a more
fundamental question of what exactly
Liberty is for and I think that both the
right and the left actually uh tend to
make a mistake when they discuss Liberty
the left tends to think that Liberty is
an ultimate good that Simple Choice
makes a bad thing good which is not true
and I think the right talks about
Liberty in almost the same terms
sometimes and I think that's not true
either the question is whether Liberty
is
of inherent value or instrumental value
is Liberty good in and of itself or is
Liberty good because it allows you to
achieve X Y or Z and I've thought about
this one a lot and I I tend to come down
on the latter side of the aisle I mean
this is you ask me areas where I move
this may be an area where I've moved is
there anything when you think more
shallowly about politics or maybe more
quickly because this is how we talk in
America is about Liberties and rights we
tend to think that the right is what
make not like the political right rights
make things good Liberties make things
good the question really is what are
those rights in Liberties for now you
have to be careful so that that doesn't
shade into tyranny right you can only
have Liberty to do the thing that I say
that you can do
but there have to be spheres of Liberty
that are roiling and interesting and
filled with debate but without
threatening the chief institutions that
surround those Liberties because if you
destroy the institutions the Liberties
will go too if you knock down the
pillars of the society the Liberties
that are on top of those pillars are
going to collapse and I think that
that's if people are feeling as though
we're on the verge of tyranny I think
that's why